This hamster eating a burrito is the cutest
thing ever.
So... obviously we have to science this cuteness,
bro.
Howdy hamster-lovers, Trace here from DNews.
Hamsters, squirrels, platypus, chipmunks,
some old-world primates, gophers all have
one thing in common -- they have food pouches.
A food pouch is like a pocket around the mouth
where food can be stored for transportation
to a den, or to slowly consume.
This amazingly cute video of a hamster eating
teeny tiny burritos has been making the Internet
rounds, and you can see the hamster shove
this burrito into its food pouch!
The pouches are huge, stretching from the
mouth all the way to the shoulders.
The tiny burrito just DISAPPEARS!
It's gone!
Where'd it go?
And that's EXACTLY what another rodent would
think.
Food pouches evolved as a way to hide food
from the competition.
Hamsters, squirrels, chipmunks and gophers
are competing for food with a LOT of other
animals!
But once the food has been squirreled away
into their food pouches, it becomes a lot
more difficult for other animals to steal
their prize.
Some, like hamsters, can then slowly consume
the food, while others, like chipmunks, push
the food back out and bury it for later.
Hamster mommas will also store their babies
in their cheek pouches!
When the mom spots a predator, her instinct
is to stuff as many babies in her pouches
as possible and wait until the danger is gone.
Hamsters aren't the smartest, because sometimes
the babies will suffocate before the mom feels
safe.
The pouches are made of a very thin and malleable
skin, which is highly stretchy, sort of like
a thin balloon.
But all that stretching means it's pretty
fragile, if a cheek pouch is pierced, the
hamster is in trouble.
But that's more important for pet owners than
the wild ones.
Platypus have cheek pouches // SPINES, BILLS,
BEAVERTAILS, NOW CHEEK POUCHES?
WHAT DON'T THOSE GUYS HAVE? // because it
hunts underwater, and carries it's prey to
the surface to munch.
Again, I nominate platypus for most weird
animal ever.
Macaques have food pouches too, and they're
the most biologically successful primate in
the old-world!
Some species of these omnivorous monkeys evolved
pouches to keep food from competing monkeys.
That way, these intelligent social animals
can hide food they'd rather not share.
It's not that the macaques are dicks... rather
that the best food is tough to come by, so
when a macaque can get a competitive advantage
to protect its find -- like cheek pouches
-- it will survive longer and be healthier.
What if HUMANS had cheek pouches?
Think about it!
I could put my phone somewhere and would never
miss a call!
What would you keep in your cheek pouches?
I'm anxiously awaiting creative answers from
the comments, this could get weird fast.
Make sure you subscribe to DNews for more
science every day of the week and you can
find us on twitter at-DNews or me at-TraceDominguez!
Be sure your pouches are empty people, you
wouldn't want anything dying up in there...
ew.